[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is I can't
believe it this is Julia Louis-Dreyfus I
say it with a question mark is she
really here
from from Veep Veep hit that p uh this
the Jerry Seinfeld Chronicles
um also she has a new podcast called
wiser than me where she talks to women
that are older than her with wisdom to
share wiser than me out now this is
incredible I can't believe she took the
time to come into our newly renovated
Studio I'm gonna say we renovated the
studio 90 because she was coming but
you'll see people that are watching this
on the video uh we finally have
everything set up shout out to Brian
Cullen by the way who designed the
studio and did an incredible job setting
it all up so maybe if you haven't seen
this on video this will be a good time
to start
um just a couple things to say up top oh
why not why not this here's a taste of
the episode before I blab on about my
tour dates here's a taste but I think
because I'm because I'm in the
television and then it turns out I'm
small people often want to hug me and
pick you up and pick me up and put me in
their pockets
put you back in their televisions really
okay now now I'll blab on about my tour
dates I'm not even gonna blab on just go
to petehomes.com I'm on the road are you
gonna be in Madison Wisconsin or
Milwaukee I'm going to be adding some
dates I'm coming back to Denver uh
that's not up yet but I mean whenever
you hear this
go to petehomes.com I'm on the road come
see if I'm going to be uh out there near
you Minneapolis in the mix
um and if you're going to be in Los
Angeles go to largo-la.com I have a
standing Show there it's one of the
greatest joys of my life and the next
one is May 4th go to largo-la.com for
tickets to that and if you like the show
why not try a Pete's pick this is uh
these are products that I actually use
and actually love like this one right
here one of our oldest and OG Pete's
picks this is Alpha Brain I'm holding it
up and I'll shake it for the audio
listeners Alpha Brain supports memory
and focus it's a new atropic it's Earth
grown ingredients that help you be
creative help you dial in help you be
focused anything that you do with your
brain Alpha Brain is my secret weapon
I'm not so secret about it I tell
everybody I have it in my coat Pockets I
have it in my car I have it in my travel
bag I have so many bottles of Alpha
Brain around my office it's a little bit
absurd because it's not like caffeine it
doesn't get you jolty it doesn't get
it's not an upper it just gives your
brain the nutrition that it needs as I
said from Earth grown ingredients not a
stimulant to die violin and to focus and
to work and to connect and to
communicate and to recall and to
remember I wish I knew about it in
college I'm so glad I know about it now
and I happen to be having an even bigger
uh discount than usual usually I say go
to onit.com weird and you can do that if
you hear this later on it.com slash
weird but right now if you're hearing
this the week it came out on its
Semi-Annual Sale is on right now with
their lowest prices on supplements
Fitness Nutrition digital apparel and
more that means 25 off Alpha Brain ten
percent off kettlebells and 60 up to 60
off doorbusters the sale ends on May
14th so hurry while supplies last go to
onnit.com or learn more at onit.com semi
Dash annual Dash sale but I'm sure if
you go to honor.com it'll tell you there
and you'll get all those discounts or if
you hear this after it comes out go to
audit.com and you'll get always get a
discount year round with our promo code
weird alright everybody let's get into
it so excited for you to hear this
episode Julia Louis she's here what do
you what what
I want to say that you're the first we
redid the studio
and it's like kinda
we sort of did it we were like trying
you were the guest we were trying to be
done believe it or not this is the
redone this is the redo this is the redo
well I I think it's good I mean yeah I'm
you should have seen it before I was
gonna say there are some like scratches
yeah don't critique well you just asked
me if I'm a [__] talker not to me oh
okay you said we said behind backs only
when you leave say to Charlotte and
William what a douchebag you are we
don't know how my personality came into
questioning this
no I the first I just want you to feel
welcome thank you I'd be excited I'm
very excited to be here are you really
yeah why not I think you're funny I like
you I like your podcasts yes and you're
a podcaster now just get it out right in
the top I am wiser than me yeah
available wherever you get your podcast
you have to say it like you don't even
know I don't know if you know if you
find out tell me where I can find wiser
than than me you can find it on Apple
and Spotify and wherever else you get
your podcasts there's other ones but we
don't know I don't know who they are
well I'm glad you're doing it isn't it a
joy it is a joy it's a lot of work yeah
I heard you say that on Conan's how do
you what do you mean what I mean is is
that I you know it's not like um
I have other friends who podcasts and
they're like oh my God it's so so much
fun just sit around talk and then it's
done but in this case that you know I'm
talking to some really like
intelligent intellectual accomplished
women yeah so women I'm just gonna
imagine sorry women what I was going to
try I have just blown your lab coats you
know Scholars right exactly no that's
the point of your podcast is that older
women I don't know where the line is do
you have a line
70-ish really I thought you were gonna
say like middle age up you're saying
they have to be older than you yeah yeah
older and wiser yes oh wow yeah how many
have you found so far I've done I've had
10 conversations okay and it's a work
it's worked because you admire them and
you want it you don't I don't want to be
I want to be super prepared and I want
to really have a thoughtful conversation
about about their experience in life and
their their experience with aging and I
mean just all of it you know it's a
thing right I mean older women the Crone
right
yeah I'm Gonna Save the Crone no mother
Maiden Crown yeah made in mother Crone
and we don't know what to do I mean I I
don't want to put words in your mouth
but it seems to me you're trying to
address like as a society it's like we
don't know what to do with our elders in
general but especially as I said the
crowns I think I think that the
the sort of the
lady
Trope yes is a bummer house made of
candy luring in children exactly yes
hunched over yes yes
and I and the old wise man on top the
hill that's right another Trope yes and
I think it's time to I would like very
much to change that narrative and you
know so that uh because I I really do
believe that older women are a natural
resource untapped very untapped you mean
we could run use them for energy yes
exactly
that is what I mean you could put them
on a bike and make them bike and then it
can create and retrieve they love bikes
they love horses
yeah but more bikes the other person you
can get the energy off of you know yeah
they're pedaling I'm just saying you
might lure them in by being like we have
salt water taffy we have horses the
things that Comfort them and this is how
I get the guests on my show you call
them on their phone one of these hello
Eisenhower like one of those and you
call them up and you say a podcast is
like a radio you know that big that's
right that thing that looks like the
front of the Chrysler water taffy that's
all you have to say swt but they the uh
um and I mean just and selfishly I just
really want I I got the whole idea for
this because I saw that Jane Fonda
documentary and yeah about you know life
in five acts that doc which for those of
your listeners who haven't
seen it it's so good edit that out and
um and I thought oh I must
I was struck by her life and how I
didn't I hadn't considered her her the
expanse of her life
um so I thought wait a minute what about
all these other older women out there
that we're not hearing from yeah I
personally would like to hear from them
and what flavor are they giving other
than saltwater Tavi what flavor are they
giving that other people aren't like
what is what are we Plumbing in these
depths what has surprised you with the
type of wisdom and advice that they're
hitting here
me
that might be an unfair question it
might be how they say it maybe it's not
what they're saying it's how they're
saying it might be a vibe that you get
like a comfort that you get tell me what
you're getting without it necessarily I
think I think the
um
I I think it's terribly interesting to
consider
uh aging and not being afraid of it and
maybe thinking about it as an ex mind
expanding experience as opposed to as
opposed to like what we lose as we age
because of course we do yeah uh but what
do we gain yeah we have none of that
we've none of that because you you stop
everything is about youth all the time
because young people can make money and
buy buy stuff I'm not trying I know
we're smoking a J in our dorm room now
but like it is it's like you're not
useful if you're not consuming or
producing and that's why I think the the
child like the pressure to have children
and when you are no menopause being like
a thing and then the later is so now
okay you're not working because you
might be not physically able or willing
or whatever it might be so you can't you
can't buy stuff and you're not producing
babies which is there's this unspoken by
is I don't mean to explain that to you
women are here to help the men make more
men or whatever it might be right does
that sound right yeah I think
I think take on it it's just straight
from my heart that's how I feel it
that's how I'm 100 JK but like where I'm
into wisdom and in other cultures it's
just understood that the LA the first
part of your life is finding a partner
having a family second part is your
career third part is is those Elder
years where you're supposed to cultivate
some inner silence some Stillness and
some wisdom and share it with people but
we have a lot of old children now we
actually don't have a lot of Elders
because they weren't indoctrinated into
that system but there are some that are
just being flat out ignored and it seems
to me that's what you're trying to
remedy yeah and I'm and I
can we put water and hold this
this is a good fully work
there's ice in there good for the rndc
we'll sell this bottle
for fifty thousand dollars anyway I
can't remember what I was saying it
doesn't matter it doesn't really matter
tell me how you feel today because
nobody cares about your podcast I'm just
kidding I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding a little touch a little touch to
say JK but tell me how you're feeling
okay why don't you just say just kidding
I mean why don't we say uh automatic
teller machine
yeah that's true
I won you over so quickly yeah it was
very quick that was really I'm pretty
proud of myself I'm curious just how
you're feeling today because like what
is your your team told me that you were
working are you in a work mode are you
in a flow mode what's your life like
currently it's a total work right now
what is that uh well uh uh
I mean it's just a just a [__] ton of
stuff just the the podcast type of movie
coming out in May which I'm very excited
about a lot of stuff about that yeah you
know I mean it's all very fabulous and
and wonderful version to your day-to-day
how are people nagging you about these
things
well they're not net first of all let's
be clear I heard you say nagging let's
be no you said it
let's be clear this is all good fortune
yeah yeah of course okay but like right
before I walked into your house I'm
sitting in my car listening to premium
content for an episode for the friendly
boats episode and then I have a photo
shoot uh for with People magazine for
the movie that's coming out and that's
happening I think tomorrow I have to
look at myself it's one of those things
and then uh yeah you're in one of those
times it's one of those says but there
these are good times I understand yeah
is that that was part of my because I
just did your I'm assuming your friend
Jason Alexander unless you want to give
us a TMZ scoop that you can't stand that
that pizza I I would rather not comment
on anything
I saw JJ I'm gonna call him JJ I saw JJ
no one calls him that nobody yesterday
because we both did a hundred thousand
dollar pyramid how is my man he's a
delight he's he's a grandfather I know
isn't that crazy yes isn't that wild yes
and he's just he just looks like a
little boy you just gave a piece of cake
that's how he always looks and that's
how he makes me feel like I just gave
him cake but speaking of cake he looks
fit and fabulous and he was a delight
and he was promoting his podcast so
here's Conan here's you here's Jason
Alexander doing podcasts are you
happiest
let's not get stuck in an interview
we're just chat we're just two ladies
chatting but are you happiest when
you're working like is that your best
place
yeah and you don't really like it what's
it like when it slows down well it's
funny you should say that because
yesterday
at around 3 30 everything all the stuff
stopped
and I didn't have anything pressing and
I had been on like okay what's next
what's next Okay click on that I gotta
Zoom with them I got it and then like 3
30 or 4 it was over yeah Power out and
it is a little uh
um I I don't quite know what to do with
myself I know that feeling sometimes I
walk around the house I tell Val my wife
I go I just sang out loud I go she is my
life like if I'm I don't know if that's
codependence but if it is it's sweet
sometimes I just Shuffle around I have
to chase me I'm not sure your wife likes
that and I don't know her particularly
well but she she loves that she loves it
okay because she feels the same way okay
we watch I watch this documentary on
YouTube about this guy who lives in like
some ice forest it was horrible I hated
it it was like a 20 minute YouTube
documentary this guy decided to live in
the forest yeah and I mean when you say
Force it's not like the Shire it's like
he lives in the worst place why
I don't know I didn't really cover that
it's it's like kind of like Thoreau I
guess he's like I'm out I'm gonna just
eat rabbits and milk thorough was in a
really nice Forest I know a beautiful
for us right and so then what happened
well this documentary grows and hangs
out with this guy and the funniest part
I mean quite a few parts were funny yeah
um it was just treachery the whole day
is he goes out he's also like 89 and he
goes out into the woods and cuts down a
tree and like has to dry it and then he
just uses that for the day see this is a
nightmare and he'll maybe catch one
rabbit drink some snow he melted and
then it the whole nightmare picks up the
next day so he had a little free time
and what he did yeah what he did Julia
in his free time was he had all these
cans like old cans and he just started
playing them with his Forks like
just pure Madness and I said that's
sometimes how I feel if like Val is gone
for a couple days and I'm just kind of
like eight o'clock rolls around like I
don't know what to do well I'll tell you
one thing I did tell me I went to bed
really early yes what's that I what's
early for me uh I'm I was in bed last
night by like eight o'clock oh that's
it is beautiful I love my bed so much
it's so cozy I have zero judgment here
and I just turned on the television
I watch Jeopardy
okay
not life
yes this is right just back to your
throw guy in the ice forest yeah yeah
um there's a show which you've probably
heard of called alone have you heard of
this show no Katie's nodding have you
seen it Katie okay
don't you think you should watch it
alone alone yeah it is a reality
but it's people going out into the
Wilderness and they just it's I don't
know how many people is it okay do you
think it's like 10 people to start and
the whole idea is you have to you you're
given very few tools like practically
nothing and you're [__] on your own
and it's whoever
and it's just like what you were
describing it's like they really have to
find their food shoot their food you
know blah blah blah it is we got so
hooked on it during real lockdown during
the pandemic peel off I'm telling you we
watched like three episodes a day we
couldn't get enough of it well yeah and
this guy is basically on that show for
no Prize or no glory yeah because the
winner gets I think a million dollars or
maybe 500 000 I can't really remember
I'll tell you one other thing about this
documentary the whole time they're they
it's like you can see them seeding a
story that his windows suck his windows
let in all the cold and you can tell
this this crew comes by with all the
stuff and you and they're like and we
decided to give I don't know his name uh
a gift and I'm like of course they're
gonna fix this [__] witness
a mug or something a mug a mug with the
name of the documentary company on it
that's perfect
true line Productions like here now you
have a new bass drum you have a new
thing for your little kit oh yeah yeah
yeah let's let's shift gears from a
documentary nobody cares about why I
think this is interesting I actually do
too I'm going to take back that
self-deprecation I've been enjoying
remembering it and watching you learn
about it thank you and feeling William
but not Charlotte Charlotte's not
interested she's not interested what is
it this is stupid but will you yes it is
I can tell already I know but I do I
really want to know as a human yeah how
does it feel to be you meaning my dad
sees you at the airport it's a whole
thing
how's that going I what are you asking
me I'm asking people coming up and
saying Elaine or wanting you to do the
dance or like what's your life like when
you're an icon not just an icon that I
know my parents know people have I don't
have to tell you my brother used to
leave dinner parties at seven o'clock to
watch Seinfeld like if he was at someone
else's dinner party wow you'd be like I
have to go and I'd go turn on their TV
so there's this like compulsive cultural
obsession with this thing I asked Jason
the same thing it's it's like what is
that feeling like are you just blocking
it out trying to normalize your life or
is it just kind of like something you've
become accustomed to what do you do when
my dad comes up well I try to be as
polite as possible to your dad sure and
and the answer is I
I
uh
and I try to live as normal life I mean
I the answer is I do all of those things
I'm also a very private person so
um but I I
you know it's I'm not it's fantastic
it's great it's like who would have
thought who would have thought
and I mean it's an incredibly it's just
nothing that it would have happened and
that it would be so warm nobody's coming
up and saying bad things yeah for the
most part I think I mean I'm sure
somebody has at some point but like I
can't I'm reaching well anyway whatever
no no no no no no I just watched you
delete a memory well
it's all been positive well I'm gonna
think everyone who listens to this
podcast knows I'm going to say this but
David Letterman said on Charlie Rose he
was like I like being famous because it
turns the world into a small town and I
can relate I was just in Houston Texas
and you walk around and people just say
like I love your comedy that's nice but
what I'm trying to get at is Seinfeld I
know you've done many many wonderful
things but specifically Seinfeld is like
this
it's like a dream the whole country had
and there's the lady from my dream and
we feel like we own you I'm not saying
that but you're in I heard Seinfeld said
Jerry say when you're on someone's TV
you're in their living room sure so
there's that I'm sure it wasn't the
first to say it but you see Bono at the
grocery store you leave Bonn alone you
see Jerry you go up to him because
that's your friend from TV that's right
yeah do you experience that I do yeah I
definitely experience that and and uh
and sometimes it can be a little bit
alarming yes you know when people really
want to
um you know I'm very short and I know
people you notice that yeah well I'm
very tall yeah how tall are you too tall
no really I'm six foot six you are my
son is six five so I'm used to these
tall people but I am not tall myself and
so I people I think because I'm because
I'm in the television and then it turns
out I'm small people often want to hug
me and pick you up and pick me up and
put me in their pocket
put you back in their televisions really
it's like when that little kid said to
Mr Rogers how did you get out of my TV I
know he's not the cutest excuse me how
much do you love Mr Rogers
um 10 out of 10 I believe 10 out of 10.
you know who else is there nobody
the best you can do is a nine nobody's
unseating Fred oh my God he is just such
a dream every time I watch any clip of
him now I just start crying I know
because I feel like it's slipping away
like what he was grasping at that
kindness and that Simplicity who is
shepherding that and that quiet yeah for
and for young children I know remember
when he was like let's see what a minute
feels like and he played he had an egg
timer set to a minute and he just sat
there and that was on TV
I mean I tried to get my daughter to
watch it but she she lit a mattress on
fire and flipped it around she was like
this this will not never do that you
know that thing that's all over the
internet that you could see people doing
it all the time where they say that that
the behavioral trick with your kid or
kids where you say okay here's this
piece of chocolate and I'm gonna walk
out of the room and don't touch it and
then when I come back I don't know why I
haven't done it you need how old are
your kids she's four you could do it we
could do it now it's a great time I have
a strong feeling this Leela is a
strong-willed Child uh she's gonna eat
that chocolate well so that would be so
interesting to know yeah I don't mean
put it up on the internet just for you
just for us I would tape it though just
you have it for your family archives and
you go if you don't eat it I'll give you
two you could do that as well but if you
do eat it you only get that one I think
Leela's just like she's a real pull the
rip cord
she's got that Vibe she's got like an
old I can't even call it I've never met
anyone like her I know I don't know many
four-year-olds but I just her Essence is
like are you she feels like an
interdimensional being who's the first
time trying to be like a person but
she's very wise right but she's like for
the first time I'm gonna see what this
[__] is and she showed up and she's
kind of like
she gets frustrated like what is this
like a lot of the time and I'm like I
know like how much of Life parenting is
telling your kids like I know this is
crazy like what we put up with the
uncertainty of it the irregularity of it
the unfairness of it right but just like
going back to the dream thing it's like
we're all having this crazy dream and
you and I as grown people have gotten
used to it you're like well there's
gravity and uh there's hunger right
there's sleep and sometimes there's
completely uncalled for anxiety right
just for no reason right and we've
gotten used to it because we've done it
for so long but they just showed up here
going like I don't understand and we're
like I know it's crazy and you just kind
of have to I know and it's fun to be
able first of all how much pot did you
smoke before this conversation none none
okay this is a natural eye yes I have to
do that to camera this isn't it thank
you yes
um I but what's so great about having
kids is when they see things for the
first time and then you get to see it
the same way that's right it's so
thorough because they're as excited as
we should be yeah but there I think
there's a neurological reason for that
is our brains have adapted not just our
psyches or our personalities have
adapted and been like well life is
sometimes unfair or sometimes you're
anxious for no reason but it's also
visually editing out things that aren't
important isn't that right and her brain
isn't doing that right so speaking of
drugs that's one of the things that
drugs can do certain drugs psychedelics
for example will stop that process and
you will see a flower in all of its
beauty or whatever and that's really not
helpful you know what I mean like it's
fun but it's not helpful that's why your
brain goes don't show them the flower
but when you and and marijuana is a mild
psychedelic as well so when you're
stoned you can see a flower in a
different way the I remember
a long time ago I took one of my sons to
the car wash and he'd never been there
before I mean he was young and so and so
the car was going through and we were
watching at the window one of the
drive-through ones so fun and he started
to cry wow what are they doing to our
car
yeah what is this felt octopus yeah he's
not wrong he's he was terrified and I
was like oh my God
but this is a that's an example of what
I'm doing yeah right you're hearing me
perfectly yeah you and I what about the
dentist he's going to Chisel your teeth
or or the doctor he's gonna poke you
don't worry it's just to inject you with
something right that's gonna change your
right Sally or whatever I'm curious
whatever it might do that's insane we're
bags of fluid the number of things that
we're overlooking it takes a whole day
to forget them yeah
did that
it's time to a heavy place yes
there were bags was it bags of fluid
yeah that was it well the first time
your kid cuts themselves and and Blood
starts coming out and you just are you
queasy are you a cuisinger no no no no
no no I'm not are you no no do you want
to
Bloodsport no okay just kidding I
thought maybe we would fight to the
death that's weird that you said no
um but the first time she starts putting
together what she is or that she's a
skeleton
oh yeah weird weird [__] or that
there's another set of teeth behind her
teeth waiting to come out
my daughter's two sets of teeth or when
they get older you'll see and they
what do you mean she has two sets of oh
because the big yeah let's not even talk
about it it's too [__] weird yeah
this is exactly my point
when the um
they get older and they start to read
for pleasure
um RFP and yeah
ATM JK
and so um
uh and you know what that was a CB
senior moment no CB yeah I know but I
thought even the senior moment extended
into the acronym no that meant call back
call back thank you so but anyway what I
was going to say was
um
he was reading oh God
yeah but what was what's Of Mice and Men
soft things and yeah and that happens at
the end I won't I won't spoiler alert it
for you know but it has very sad sad I
feel like alternative events and he came
in I know I'm kidding but he came into
he was reading it's probably maybe
fourth grade and he came in and just
balling
and I I and I just remember
I yeah anyway I I'm just amusing on the
same thing over and over again you're
we're in a jazz band and you have a
trumpet and you're playing beautifully
that is exactly correct you're hearing
the theme that I established yes and and
I'm improvising I'll hit the ball back
with this yes I used to go on walks with
my mom mom walks I was just dad's out
where's Dad he's working he's at a ball
game with my brother I'm strolling with
the ladies yeah and if we saw a squirrel
get hit by a car immediately I just
start bawling just bawling and my mom
knew you'd see it and you're like this
doesn't look good for the squirrel I'd
pre-go into her to be like because it's
[__] nuts like how many squirrels are
getting killed in your neighborhood it
was a problem yeah there was a guy
seemed to be aiming for or maybe stupid
squirrels I mean maybe they're really
dumb in your neck of the woods I feel
like if it's not in regards to storing
acorns they're dumb as they're dumb as
[__] they're dumb as beans what's your
biggest problem with your husband what
do you get on him the most about what in
the living hell did that come from look
I listened to Conan's podcast not to
shoot down the big dog but what a snooze
let's keep it moving
this guy's going on and on about how
great Veep is who gives a [__]
incredibly I'm saying the nice things
he's incredibly intelligent he is he can
fix any okay I'm going to say this but
we have to touch wood because I don't
want to jinx it yeah it's so good at
fixing all computer technological things
like it's unbelievable okay it's a great
sense of humor he's very generous he's
very kind I met him at the thing you met
him tall too there's he's very tall your
son although my mom's side of the family
also very tall I just got the shrimp
Gene but whatever
um sounds delicious he's
um uh yeah and he's maybe
a little bit uh forgetful he's a
forgetter
a little bit he has he has something
that actually my son has too sort of
it's called I think it's called object
impermanence like peekaboo he'd be
fooled by peekaboo
I mean that's what object impermanence
is it is yeah if I disappear behind this
I no longer exist that's what object
impermanence oh I see well okay well
maybe that's one version of it but in
his case and also in my son's case it's
very hard for them to keep hold of
things
if that makes sense he comes in he'll
put his the keys down and then that's
just like a literal in the material in
the three dimensions their objects are
impermanent yeah
yeah I understand so it's not really
that big of a complaint what what
complaint do you have about your wife
yeah I would never what if I just don't
answer I would never have a complaint
but sell them out for a podcast like I
just did JK of course Val
um it's hard to know what Val really
thinks
and I would say that she's going to
listen to this it and I love that about
her if Val doesn't like something I
sometimes have to like interpret like
I'll say do you want to go uh to this
thing and she'll be like yeah and I'm
like that's a no that's a hard no oh I
say well that's the excuse me those are
relationship Dynamics RDS what do you
mean like how does that FS
friendship for sure
foreign
here's another example yesterday we're
dropping Leela off at school I know Val
has to pee we were coming back from LA
to get Leela at school she's talking
about how she has to pee I have to pee
I'm going to explode I have to pee we
pull into the parking lot we get out
there's one of the kids moms I blow
right past him I'm gonna go get my
daughter hi nice to see you Val starts
talking to them I almost was like I know
like her lawyer or her Secret Service I
should go she has to pee she has to pee
right now I go and get Leela I sign her
out I come back she's still talking I
yell Val go pee that's that's one of the
things that I'm like it's not like a big
problem for me but I'm like she would
admit she needs to get better at going
like pee I need to pee you know what I
mean and and was she happy that you said
that yeah I think so I think we help
each other out we have a good we I
called her a relationship yesterday the
perfect Arnold Palmer oh nice I think we
got a really good blend oh I like that
you seem to have a good blend with your
partner I do how does he deal with the
because Val I don't want to say she
cuddles me but she knows that this
business has UPS Downs has the 330s
where everything shuts off yeah does he
do well with is he a steady Eddie or is
he also like total steady Eddie always
has been always has been yeah just
because he's a intellectual guy has a
lot of interests uh he's he's just
um
I mean I like to be with him you know I
like to be with him it's nice key to a
successful relationship yeah I just like
to be with him with them yeah and you
probably I'm putting words in your mouth
but tell me if you agree yeah you feel
more yourself with him there like
there's not a you're not putting on a
show you can go now just Julia
yeah and you know what else too like
I've had occasionally I've been away and
I've been on uh location shooting
something and he hasn't been able to be
with me and after a period of time
that's it's it's hard to for me anyway I
mean we've been married a long time
we've been together a long time uh to be
by myself past a certain amount of time
yes yeah it's like I'm yeah exactly and
I might get some of those cans because I
have to go to it away in a couple couple
months and I have to be gone for a while
and I think I'm gonna get some cans and
sticks yes yes look
feel free to Dodge I think it's a
beautiful question it's sort of a
classic question but I know I got into
show business because I I like the way I
feel when I'm being engaged with like I
like being heard and I like hearing
people and I grew up in a house where I
was sort of like does anyone hear anyone
like there was like that's the classic
part are you in touch with what and it
doesn't have to be bad but like what
drove you because it is there's sort of
a compulsive quality to wanting to
perform to wanting to make other people
laugh and I know that's a classic you
know shrink thing but I'm interested in
if you're in touch with them
well I like uh
I think that it is the pretend of it all
the pretend uh
um pretending to be a character and
really getting
just like down and dirty with it and
really rolling around in a role yeah
um is
good for my psyche
um and maybe because it
I think it was sort of a savior to me as
a child uh and it was almost in a weird
way centering and so and that's and and
I just feel very comfortable
um being challenged by the experience of
pretending to take on a character is it
like a bubble experience yeah yeah so
you the outside world falls off falls
off yeah and of course that's very
comforting again feel free to dodge but
what was it what does it feel like when
you're not in that bubble I'm a highly
sensitive person I get freaked out I
like doing stand-up comedy but if you
think about it stand up is a incredibly
controlled circumstance just like being
on set the lights are in certain places
your Your Mark is in a certain place
your clothes it's a control freaks dream
whereas I think other people look at it
and they go like how can you go out and
perform and and aren't you nervous yeah
but you but stand up but stand up is
really different don't you think I mean
I think
and I don't mean different in a bad or a
good way I just mean it's a different
Beast I think it is but what I'm the
there's a bubble quality to it some
people might go
oh the tension that there's these people
looking at you and I'm I'm more thinking
about the bubble that's created where
I'm like everything goes away like
you're saying you you roll around with
it I'm playing the role of a stand-up
comedian but I'm completely lost for
that hour and you come back and you
might as well have been there was
efforting for sure but it feels like you
took a week-long nap or something right
right and so I'm wondering are you I
think those are the dopamines or
whatever it is for sure absolutely
there's a lot of reward chemicals
happening I always say this but the guy
the free solo guy that climbed the
mountain I'm like these guys are trying
to shut off their minds you know what I
mean it's not just I love being low and
then I love getting high very slowly
they want to shut off their brains so is
the world an overwhelming place to you
can be sure yeah um how how could it not
be really I don't know I see a lot of
people at dinner parties just having a
fun time you put me in a dinner party I
I I'm not enjoying it I I don't like it
you're not a dinner you're not a dinner
party person what happens
I just I I'm quietly envious that people
are just kind of like okay with how loud
it is that's one
how is everyone okay with how loud it is
why am I yelling North Dakota
North Dakota like how was your show how
am I gonna [__] tell you app etizers
are getting dropped I don't like it I
like this right the thing that I like
about Pete is Pete looks out for Pete
and Pete figured out that Pete likes
one-on-one conversations so Pete made a
podcast it's beautiful I say I know this
is work and press or whatever but I like
this kind of conversation we can really
hear each other and I can lock onto you
okay but wait a minute so do you ever
have like a couple come to your house
and have dinner do you ever do that I'll
do that that's more calm do it in fact
I'll do a dinner party at my house
uh-huh I just don't want to do it in
like a loud restaurant
but you're not that way you can enjoy a
party hey we're going to the WME party
are you gonna have fun uh absolutely and
I'm not going absolutely not and I'm not
going tell me why I don't it's too it's
um
it's it's too businessy it's too um
phony yeah of course I mean I understand
people have to go to those things and
you know rub elbows and all the rest of
it but I would prefer to skip it okay
we're going to a party of my friend
we're good friends yeah in this scenario
yes and I'm going to a party but you're
not going to know anybody just kind of
like a regular party are you gonna enjoy
that
you know there's a punch bowl no I'm not
going to that party okay yeah I'm not
and tell me why what are the feelings
that make that it's just I'm kind of I'm
already sort of feeling tired
and what is the tired protecting
it's a lot of work to go to a party like
that yeah I think you know and it's
exhausting and it's a little tiring yeah
yeah it's a little time I I prefer again
I mean it's not like I don't go to those
kind of parties but I prefer a gathering
of
um a smaller Gathering of people that
you know so that you can actually have a
proper conversation although I will say
this I do like to play games games are
great games are great because isn't
shooting a movie a game it's the same
thing it's a structure yes that's why I
love being on set too it's like we're
all pointed in the same direction yes
we're all on this team we're all on this
team yeah that's right totally and if we
like each other it bleeds through that's
right speaking of did you and James
Gandolfini love each other because when
I watched that movie yes I I'm like
there's because I heard a rumor that if
actors hate each other I heard Scarlett
Johansson and Bill Murray didn't like
each other but that reads his love in
loss in Translation really and you guys
we just watched it for pleasure I was
like Julia's doing it this week we just
threw it on because we love it please
tell me that it was as much of a joy as
it seemed to be it really was and that's
really what he was like I believe it
he's he was very much a
um a deer kind of tender guy with a lot
of insecurity interesting yes yeah and
uh quiet like kind of soft-spoken and
yeah and a little bit he could be a
little combative
like with material uh you mean
creatively combative yeah I don't mean
he was misbehaved but I do mean he was
resistant that's the word trade term
that he was misbehaved no no but he was
resistant to sometimes to direction that
Nicole Hall of Center wrote and directed
that movie and sometimes he would be
uh uh resistant to trying her suggestion
directorily or a particular line change
or whatever right and that sensitivity
too right that's that's yeah I think I
think so and it came from a I think it
did come from a place of insecurity and
I would just Badger him into it yeah but
I really was fond of him
treasure especially since we've lost him
watching it it's like this time capsule
of and I I'm just glad I have the chills
that you confirmed I'm like I feel like
this is yeah and as a matter of fact
when I
um I was at the Emmys uh app and this is
after he had passed and Edie Falco came
up to me and she was like I'm so glad
you made that movie because that's
really who he was and I said I know I
know it was nice it was nice for her to
say that that's the perfect that's like
a bronzable compliment yeah it really
was it is it's a gift yeah it's so great
and that chemistry which is kind of hard
to do in general when you're trying to
make chemistry with somebody is that
efforting or do you just hope it works
on the day
do you like hang out beforehand we did a
little hangout we did rehearsing and
stuff like that but you know how you can
sort of uh you get a sense of somebody
pretty quickly as to whether or not yeah
and uh yeah I I knew it would work with
him that's
yeah he's a really nice guy glad I
thought to ask that yeah I let's Okay
this is another very specific question
all right I was doing a guest spot on a
multicam recently
and I was like I'm gonna do a voice I'm
just I feel like this guy's I know I'm
gonna try a voice I'm just gonna give it
a little
because he what I talk very fast I'm
high processing right so I talk fast and
that's an indication of a character it's
a character trait that somebody talks
fast right yeah this guy's dumb he
doesn't talk fast so I was like how do I
sound when I talk slow and I kind of
playing with it it starts getting a
little Keanu just a little Keanu is
creeping in can I hear it it's probably
like hi what's hey hey Julia subtle yeah
but still still a swing okay I'm not
sure it's subtle
I'm not sure it's subtle I Krasinski to
the camera
and feelings hurt
no no no no no no no but wait a minute I
have based a career I'm not subtle so
don't take this I'm not knocking you in
any way Julia I've never felt closer to
you than when you said I don't know if
it was subtle kind of like when I said
no one cares about your podcast and you
left it was the best moment for both of
us and we loved it what I'm saying is
you live in that tension and oh to
finish the story Betsy uh the director I
do take one take two even and I'm doing
it
she comes over here and she just goes
she's she's a she's a palamide and she
just goes like it's getting a little
Bill and Ted's that's what she said ah
and I just dropped it
I wonder how many
your job is to take risks yeah and it's
[__] embarrassing and it's difficult
yeah and does that bring anything to
mind a time when you made a move that
you weren't sure about like you're is it
gonna play did someone ever have to
correct you course correct you to
protect you from doing something that
was dumb
oh I'm certain of it I have um I'm
trying to remember I I wish I could give
you an actual story here but all I was
ever doing was trying weird bizarre
things
with the with the hope of course that
they would land but you know I I uh of
course correct I'll take you off the
hook for for an anecdote it's more like
you relate to the feeling of like do you
get a little nervous you're like I'm
gonna do this thing and the writers are
here what if it's the wrong play oh my
God yeah because you seem so
forged in steel I'll give you a specific
no no I'm not I love it definitely not
I'm definitely not I don't think people
know that I mean I have a lot of
experience now under my belt so there's
certain things I do sort of have a sense
of but when you're trying
and you know new [__] out there yeah it
can be a little Bill intense I just put
us in the same category but again we're
the same no it can't be yeah no I can't
but what I think is funny is if you go
back 21 years old SNL youngest uh female
or just youngest all time I'm not sure I
think I heard you understand oh no not
youngest of all time because I think uh
uh Eddie Murphy was in utero no um I
can't remember the guy's name but anyway
the guy who's was dating all those girls
P Davidson yeah I think he's the
youngest the guy who is dating all those
girls I love that can you cut that out
you cannot I forbid what's wrong with
the guy that was dating all those girls
that is the best Neil Brown somebody has
Neil Brennan they were like are is our
comedians in trouble and they're like
Colin just is dating Scarlett Johansson
Pete Davidson's dating Kim Kardashian I
think they're doing fine like can we
stop acting like they're an endangered
species but yes we'll take it out you
want and whatever anyway
I don't know here's my question yes
you're 21 years old I watched you on SNL
just to you know remember
and what I really what's up I just
already that you're just watching it I
just am dying on the inside but really
carry no no carry on here it comes
you're gonna love it no no you're I
think you're gonna like the area
well let's go
go
I was struck that your voice literally
your voice the way that you talk on Veep
now as I'm talking to you which is a
very funny way of talking you know what
I mean by that I don't mean it's like a
joke I mean like there's a musicality to
it it's engaging it's interesting and
it's Unique just like your Heroes
Lucille Ball just to make it less exotic
I am also speaking in my comedic
affectation which is based on yeah
research this is how you get people to
listen to you you have to modulate you
have to change but you have a very
specific I know I sound like Tony
Robbins get him listen to that one but
you 21 I'm I'm like surely she had a lot
to learn but there you were I saw the
Julia that's here today even at that age
really I did I meaning anyone listening
to it would go that's that's Julia
Louis-Dreyfus even if they didn't know
you were in this and on there you are
21. tell me a little bit about where are
you putting that together and where are
you trying it out I know you have your
Heroes but where were you building that
voice before you got SNL I was never I
don't
I don't ever thought about a voice I
just mean your artistic voice not lit I
know I was talking about literally your
voice oh
um
I mean are you kidding me I was doing it
from the from the earliest age possible
I mean for your friends and family
totally I had a I had a we did shows in
the basement we charged my parents come
down to watch and they were excellent
Productions by the way yeah
I had a theater troupe we called
ourselves the university players
this was with my neighbors yeah oh you
you cast a wide net for the talent
totally it was a massive casting call
and we had and also I had a modern dance
troupe called Julia and the umbrella
people and we I mean why umbrella people
I don't know I thought it sounded pretty
groovy
I mean and you know it does you're very
close to like what they would call
something Off-Broadway you know what I
mean like you nailed it yeah thank you
yeah and so
um
the but our our big claim to fame was a
production of sorry wrong number which
was a uh yeah right which was sort of a
thriller what did you get from my face
that you said yeah right yeah only delay
okay sorry wrong number if you date this
no no it was sorry wrong number was a
play and actually and also a film that
was from the mid early 1950s I believe
and our team over here is going to be
Googling that for us as we as I'm
talking to you and they'll get back to
us shortly with the correct information
and I played Mrs Stevenson who was the
lead uh who is trying but someone's
breaking into her apartment she's an
invalid and she is trying to get help
and so that was the play that we did
That's Heavy material no kidding
it's super heavy but I had five and
six-year-olds in it I swear to you I did
I did and they were [__] their lines
up and it really pissed me off you were
into it oh yeah can I I mean for real I
remember this one kid he didn't say the
line right and I was like God damn it
yes and he was five
oh my God
and that boy I grew up
he's actually quite fine
I relate so hard do we have the year
oh I'm sorry
let my employee look it up for you
sorry it's okay whatever meme you're
sharing they're going to Barbra strem
face cream which is what I need at least
they better be yes that's just a
reminder that she wants the light
is it the light classic which is another
word for light I believe no okay felt
like that could have been delivered with
less attitude can we do another take on
that that's the only one I got I relate
so hard I made little VHS camcorder
movies and took them very seriously we
made a movie called The Terminator which
was Kermit the Frog in a Terminator 2
jacket because Terminator 2 was out
perfect and my friend Ern I still make
fun of him for it his name's Aaron we
call him earn one of the lines was let's
just say I watch a lot of MacGyver
and I I didn't know the term but I
wanted him to throw it away
[__] does it to the camera ruins
the joke he goes let's just say I watch
a lot of MacGyver I'm like that but we
didn't do takes it was it we had it he
couldn't go back like I guess he could
you could have but you didn't think to
do it yes and I was livid I was like you
like a little bit yeah I was like that
what a plate if you hadn't done it yeah
the absolute worst let me tell you
something all this play business yeah
it's serious it's a serious business
it's a serious business it is and it
mattered it mattered it laughs matter
and acting matter drama man yes I'm
surprised that it wasn't a comedy though
when did it when did your when did you
hone in that you were like I think it's
more the hahas
um I could just mean it
the jobs I got but because I did
dramatic stuff like when I was in
college I did three Penny Opera and and
uh Joe egg I remember I did that play
these are all the uh dramas and uh but
then when I got hired professionally it
seemed to always be in comedy so it
wasn't like I was gunning for comedy
stuff you know interesting yeah we won't
dwell on Seinfeld because I don't want
to dwell on the obvious but here's
that's other than SNL that's your most
regular long-running comedy thing were
you like trying to pick up tricks and
techniques or was it just kind of like
this is this is a character this is a
scene you know where you're trying to be
bright and tight like certain words
uh I don't know what you mean I don't
understand the question I'm not kidding
were you looking at it like just another
job or were you like let me really learn
about comedy now let me study the
techniques and the moves and and the
tricks really of the great so that I can
like hack my way into a better comedic
performance oh I think I
I was studying I mean because I grew up
watching you know Lucy and and
[__] uh on the family and that was an
you know and um
and Mary and and films I mean I it was
all I was about was watching these
things so that when I think in addition
to just the experience of being an actor
by the time I got to set it was like
that was just sort of baked in all that
stuff you know it doesn't mean I knew it
all but but it was in there oh yeah and
it was really about not so much
uh oh and I'd also done a lot of um
improvisational work when I was in
Chicago that was that's a huge skill set
to bring to any work
I did Second City I did practical
theater company in Chicago and so that
that's just like a major major skill set
to bring to work to any work as a
character drama or comedy by the way of
course yeah you were in a main stage
review at Second City no I wasn't I was
in the touring company oh the Torgo yeah
oh wow yeah were you no I I was
summarily rejected that's all right it's
okay it wasn't that much fun for me
actually I didn't love it I loved
working with another theater company
called practical theater company which
was my husband's Theater Company back
then and we had we did shows that were
which were a [__] ton of fun and
successful too A better fit yeah I
didn't know what I was getting into like
had I booked it I was new this is weird
I was I got married when I was 22 and
our honeymoon was driving to Chicago
that's how obsessed I was with comedy I
was like I'm gonna audition for Second
City yeah I didn't get it but had I
gotten it it's I'm not saying you need
to be single but it helps if you're
gonna like tour around and like leave or
what if I had gotten um The Improv
Olympic that they do in Amsterdam you
know what I mean it's just like I guess
we're going to live in Amsterdam for
three months the weird 22 year old with
a wife like he just didn't I didn't
understand how much being a free agent
being a young person that could kind of
move anywhere would have been an asset
right I was trying to be a little
husband got it which was super weird
yeah you got it and did is that what you
didn't love about it was all the travel
I'm assuming oh it wasn't uh it wasn't
well run and we were we were doing other
people's material and everybody was
insanely uh high and if there were a lot
of drugs and it was a lot of uh people
with there was a lot of bitterness and
in fighting and competition it was not
my cup of tea I I'm I much prefer where
I'd come from and then where I
ultimately you know went to I mean and
that's what when by the time I started
working on Seinfeld the beauty of it was
that it was a proper Ensemble and
everybody was very much just trying to
work together to elevate what was
phenomenal material but it enhance it
even further and it was teamwork and if
and and that was just
Sublime of course
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at lmnt element my newest
morning routine which I absolutely look
forward to and love because healthy
hydration isn't just about drinking
water it's about drinking water plus
electrolytes because you lose both When
you sweat so both need to be replaced to
prevent muscle cramps headaches and
energy dips also there's neuro
connectivity things going on when
electrolytes are flush in your body most
people are only replacing water because
they always told us to drink eight
glasses of water per day even if you
weren't thirsty but that's actually a
terrible idea it deludes blood dilutes
blood electrolyte levels especially
sodium which can lead to headaches low
energy cramps confusion or worse so the
solution to getting through your workout
and just getting through your day with
proper hydration to optimize your body
and your mind is element
lmnt I just got obsessed with their
chocolate flavor I didn't think I would
like it for some reason it is my
absolute favorite I've started drinking
hot which is incredible element is a
huge part of my wellness program you mix
it up watermelon salt is my other
favorite flavor good to go no sugar no
artificial junk just a packet that you
pour into the water Stir It Up and off
you go provide it providing the optimal
ratios for sodium potassium and
magnesium for health performance and
energy it also tastes incredible an
element has come up with a fantastic
offer for us weirdos just go to drink
lmnt.com weird and use promo code weird
to get a free element sample pack with
any order when you order and if element
doesn't exceed your expectations they
offer a no questions asked refund policy
you don't even have to send it back so
support your body support the show go to
drink
lmnt.com weird to get your free sample
pack with any purchase and see how good
proper hydration feels coursing through
your body I freaking love it
drinkelement.com weird
sorry about that we're also brought To
Us by our friends at Pym choose prepare
your mind Pym choose help you manage
feelings of stress anxiety and overwhelm
it is a wonderful tool when you are
feeling worried stressed out or as we
like to say on the show you have just a
bee in your belly you can't settle in
you can't face your inbox you can't face
that workload Pym choose two delicious
naturally flavored no sugar added shoes
and in minutes you start to feel more
centered calm and control this is my
go-to when I can't face my workload I
just can't open up the laptop I actually
have them right here wasn't even
planning that I pop in two pyms and
within minutes I am ready to get into
flow when I first try them they were so
incredible I thought it was too good to
be true I bought subscriptions for my
mom and my brother just so happy that
anxiety and stress have a natural
non-addictive non-psychoactive solution
I take it as I said before I'm working I
sometimes also take it in the morning
just to ease into whatever I'm up to or
at night to wind down how do they do it
Pym Chooser comprised of proven excuse
me amino acids and complexes and
adaptogens that help support your body
and your brain's ability to organically
support and manage and tolerate stress
anxiety and overwhelm they also make
mood magnesium which helps me fall
asleep at night I take it at night with
after my pyms sleep throughout the night
and wake up feeling rested so mood
magnesium which includes the three
magnesiums with the most evidence to
support their effects on stress and
sleep everything on their website guys
is going to help with these things but
especially the the mood shoes which I
love and mood magnesium so help your
body fight off stress and overwhelm and
sleep more deeply with Pym and show your
support of the show go to you
canpym.com weird and use promo code
weird for 15 that's u y o u as in you
you can p-y-m like prepare your mind you
can pym.com weird and use promo code
word for 15 percent
off last but not least were brought to
us by our friends at Sunday lawn care if
you're like me you love spring but you
may not love figuring out how to take
care of your yard does anyone else stand
in the store wondering where to start
well that's where Sunday lawn care comes
in Sunday is everything you need to get
the lawn you have dreamed of this spring
Go to getsunday.com weird enter your
home address and get a customized plan
created just for your lawn I did it it's
super cool what they can do all online
within minutes no trips to the store or
hauling heavy bags since they ship
straight to your home plus all you need
is a hose to apply Sunday Leela actually
does it with me we attach it to the hose
and just spray it on fertilizing the
whole lawn in less time than it takes to
watch an episode of your favorite TV
show and they only use ingredients you
can feel good about no harsh chemicals
no long waiting periods or trying to
keep your kids and your pets off the
lawn simply apply let it dry and you're
back to enjoying your yard best of all
Sunday is easy and 4 affordable some
lawn care services cost more than
fifteen hundred dollars a year but
Sunday's full season plan starts at just
a hundred and nine dollars and listen to
this this is a new offer for a limited
time Sunday is offering weirdos 50 off
half off your first box so you can get
started today for as little as 55 bucks
when you go to
getsunday.com weird and 50 off your
first box go to
getsunday.com weird alright everybody
back to Julia Louis
I just I shot something last year on
Stage Nine at Radford oh you did and uh
the DP Wayne was your GP oh really Wayne
was there yeah wow I would ask him a lot
of Seinfeld questions I won't ask you
but one thing that stood out was that
you guys didn't improvise which I I
didn't do alts even I mean like I
thought right it was like kind of one
two three that's what he said
things would have happen that would if
they work they would get folded into the
script but it wasn't improvising like we
did on Veep which was a lot but again we
had a script on Veep but a lot of
improvising that was sort of folded back
into the the stew of the material right
uh but
um that's you know but I mean these
evenings would go late the shooting I
can't [__] remember what we were
um why it would go so late I guess
because sometimes uh maybe sometimes
scenes weren't quite working and then
there would be rewriting there on the
Fly the the sea was angry that day my
friends was written like 20 minutes
before right and I remember that that
story that did that ever happen did you
ever have to learn something very very
quickly oh yeah I'm sure but I can't
remember a detail like that that was an
amazing moment yeah no I didn't know
anyone could learn a monologue that
quickly from the story apparently you
just read it through a couple times and
just well so well it helps when
something's really well written which
that was yeah and if it's very very well
written sometimes it's pretty easy to
memorize that's right the lines are sort
of linked very clear together yeah the
other sort of synchronicity so Jason was
on Pyramid yesterday and so was Rosie
O'Donnell who I didn't know also
auditioned for Elaine I just kind of
thought that was an interesting
yeah right isn't that wild yeah would
you tell me about the audition process
do you remember I mean yeah it was not
really an audition because what happened
was I mean it was and it wasn't I I had
been on SNL and I I was on it for three
years and in my third year Larry David
was on it
and uh he uh yeah and Larry and I became
friends
um because we were really both pretty
unhappy in SNL and he wasn't getting his
material on and they weren't using me
and I was you know it was it was a
relatively miserable experience and we
sort of shared that you know together
right anyway so then which by the way
can I just say the chances it doesn't
even seem to have everything to do with
Talent meaning can you be talented in
this environment in this kind of
structure in this kind of like it's like
a machine that some people gel with and
some people don't so it doesn't surprise
me that you guys were like feeling like
outcasts yeah yeah yeah and
um
anyway and so then he went off I you
know we really weren't in touch for a
couple years I did a few uh what was I
do oh yeah I did I did a series or
whatever in Ella in LA Cat moved here
and did that and then all of a sudden I
picked up it was it was like it had two
it was with uh Gary Goldberg's company
it was called uh day by day I did that
for two years I believe we did it anyway
whatever
it was a sitcom it was a sitcom about a
daycare center and I was the snarky
neighbor no way yeah so you were kind of
in the system you were in I was a little
bit I was in the system that's right and
actually I had a lot of fun doing that
show
um and so anyway
and then that show ended and I and then
my agent called and said uh Larry
David's written these scripts and you
know they'd love for you to give read
blah blah four Scripts
they'd already shot the pilot I wasn't
in the pilot yeah I remember and so and
Kramer as a dog and Kessler and so I
read those four scripts and I was blown
away by the material but I didn't have a
lot to do in two of the four scripts but
the material was so like [__] weird
and out there and so unlike anything
that was on television at the time
that and of course I knew there
so I went in to see Larry and Jared was
there and I kind of recognized Jerry
because he was doing he was a stand-up
like he had done uh Carson and stuff but
I I you know I don't know the stand I
didn't know the stand-up world at all
but you know anyway we just hung out he
was eating cereal we were just hanging
out and then it sounds like you're
making it up now
Larry's complaining right but I mean it
did have that Vibe it was like they were
being who they are they were being who
they are it wasn't like you know
Executives that you're going in front of
la la la yeah and so then Jerry and I
went into an office and we read the
first scene of the I don't know what I
can't remember what episode it is maybe
it's a Stakeout I don't know anyway we
just sat in the couch and read this
scene
um then and we were joking around and
laughing and that was the end of it and
so then I then I left the offices and
Larry came running out and he said what
do you think do you want to do it and I
said yeah but I was actually they didn't
let you leave
they didn't what they didn't let you
leave you're trying to leave and he runs
no no I was walking down the sidewalk he
came out after me yeah and he said what
are you think and I said I hope we can
make it work I actually had another it
was a long story but anyway sidewalk
offer it wasn't even an offer it was
just like I mean it felt like a I don't
know how to say this I know it has all
this import the show and everything but
then it was just like a friend of mine
was doing a show yeah you understand
what I'm saying yeah and so he was like
and I was like yeah I mean I really like
it it's really fun let's you know anyway
they made a deal over the weekend we
shot the following week wow yeah I mean
it had to make the deal lickety-split
because they were on and I didn't have
to go test uh that you know they do
these test deals in Show Business and I
didn't have to do that because NBC
already knew me from SNL and from this
uh from day by day which helped it did
help actually you and Jerry must have
had
howling laughing yeah really yeah and
the director Tom sharonis was in that
room so he was sort of watching us do
the scene together it was fun it was the
scene in which he says uh you want to go
out to eat and I said and he's and I say
sure and he says where do you want to go
and I say I don't care I'm not hungry it
was that scene yeah but even that line
that I don't care I'm not hungry it was
like huh is that a joke or not it was
like it's just weird yeah and it was I I
really uh
I I I got into that
I caught into that yeah I I like it I
love I just I'm admiring your eloquence
I'm surprised I just used that as a verb
were you making each other laugh in the
scene or was it an off-page chemistry or
both I think it was both yeah I'd be
curious to ask Jerry what his memory is
of that yeah that's very fun but at the
time
obviously nobody it's just a show it's
just your friends it's a small pickup
it's a six episode four my friends the
season was four four it was like this
Show's going nowhere it's going nowhere
yeah it's like it's a replacement it's a
mid-season yeah kind of they snuck it in
through late night programming I'm
telling you it never would have and I
thought after we made those four I
thought oh my God this Show's so good
they're too stupid to pick it up because
I thought it's just so unusual never
ever pick it up and I think it only got
picked up on like a fluke kind of like
they didn't have anything else they
picked it up as a mid-season right oh
you mean after the four yeah then we did
13 episodes okay so you had a time off
of an uncertainty yeah I don't really
remember it very well neither do I and I
really it's on me to have done that
research so I'm embarrassed oh well but
it's on me it's my life I can't [__]
remember it
all I know is Seinfeld has been used as
the example of no one gives shows a
chance anymore and everyone always says
Seinfeld would have been canceled based
on numbers yes after the first four
after the first season yes that it
wasn't a hit but somebody sort of
unheard of in the in the biz now went on
their gut they were just sort of like I
don't know I like it you know what I
mean it just doesn't it doesn't seem to
happen anymore this is why we're seeing
reboots yeah you know they're going to
do
everything's going to be reimagined and
resold because they just want
um uh what is it called
engagement they don't they don't want an
ensemble that has chemistry they want
something that go like we have the
numbers people like Tetris make a movie
about Tetris I actually enjoyed that
movie I'm just saying that's kind of how
things seem to be getting made these
days yeah just a shame it is a shame
um on the other hand there are all these
opportunities to make material in so
many different I mean yes right so
there's that you could make the pilot of
Seinfeld with iPhones now you know what
I mean yeah yeah right which is we take
it for granted but you have I mean you
could edit it in your phone and and get
it at a similar Point yeah as a pilot in
the 90s yeah it's just a question of
somehow breaking through the noise when
did it start to feel clear that it was a
hit for you is there a moment when you
were like I think we're on to something
well I I'll tell you the I mean it's
sort of slowly
it's sort of slowly crept up on us but I
will say
also by the way I had both of my
children during this time so my focus
was majorly split it really was you know
and I had these and I brought the babies
to work with me and I had a nursery set
up and so my uh
I had a foot in both worlds
very firmly planted was that helpful
because here's a kind of a skyrockety
yeah I think in retrospect it was yes I
think it was it was a a grand reminder
of the significance of or of
um the priorities of life that's right
don't believe this I mean isn't that a
risk I I I've heard your perspective on
work and I think it's beautiful it's
just what I do get over it's okay it's a
privilege it's a joy but let's not take
ourselves too seriously yes would you I
mean is that how I feel I do yes
wouldn't you I mean I I see it eating at
people you mentioned substance abuse I
mean like there's a lot of like the only
good feeling is being at the top and
anything else is is death so we're gonna
bang out the best and keep delivering
and then if when and in the between
times we're gonna do cocaine like I
think those things are related yes it's
intolerable so having children I can say
for me was like this beautiful wake-up
call to go like oh I've been under a
spell I see that oh that's the meaning
of life right got it right because they
don't have any
they don't have any of that we've
learned that being sparkly and special
and and shiny and funny these are these
are valuable things I remember when we
were doing the final very final episode
of Seinfeld and
they had to they had to put uh what are
those things called like a big walls up
um on the on Bradford at the gates of
the studio because there were there were
Paparazzi and all sorts of people trying
to get with a long lens of pictures and
video of who was coming onto the Sound
Stage who was going to be in the final
episode and I remember being shocked by
that wow I was like seriously does
anybody really give that much of a [__]
yeah someone's better than you being
like of course dress like Carmen San
Diego of course this is normal no no I
mean I but I do remember thinking that
and then one time we were uh
one time we were in New York uh this is
me and Jerry and Jason and Michael we
were all there and because we had to
shoot that Rolling Stone we did a cover
of Rolling Stone which were dressed like
rock stars or whatever and so then we
thought after the shoot we'd all go out
to dinner and we'd go and we would sit
on the
um
sit on the sidewalk they had outdoor
seating at this one place on Columbus
and we thought we're gonna blow
everybody's mind
four of us all together it's gonna be
crazy not one [__] person said
anything or stopped except a homeless
man God love him who was completely out
of his mind and was just babbling about
something it was a very nice reality
check uh I remember it vividly it's
important though I mean you see people
go off the reservation I don't know if
we're still saying that but it's like
going out of their minds a little bit
going out of their minds yeah and it's
good to stay balanced and the family and
your husband
is in Show Business yes yes but not in
front of the camera is that correct yeah
although he's been in front of the
camera recently isn't he's in he's been
in a couple of things uh
he was in um
what is the American Auto American Auto
with auto American Idol no no no
American Auto with uh Anna gosteyer and
he's in a movie and stuff coming out so
he does a little bit of everything but
staying balanced it's not a cuckoo
cuckoo bananas yeah
that's really nice yeah I wonder is
there any spiritual life to speak of let
me preface it with this we're going to
church afterwards we're going to pray
okay
who's your god real quick who's your god
the guy that's going to pray who do you
worship Elohim
um
I was at an Eckhart Tolle retreat in
Rhinebeck New York have you been to
Rhinebeck no beautiful okay I just feel
like you're a classy lady you're gonna
love Rhinebeck New York all right
get me a real estate agent right now I'm
buying properties if you go to Rhinebeck
I'll make a wager you're gonna buy
property you're gonna find a way to it's
it's the most quaint off the Metro North
little town but classy some of the best
restaurants in the world how long is the
train ride out of the city I think it's
about 90. it's about 90 minutes maybe
two maybe two hours it's not Woodstock
okay you know what I mean yeah it's like
doable pull it up on Zillow right now
it's gorgeous you'll feel like Mary
Oliver you'll ride around we walk around
and write poems when Val and I were
there yeah we can't go there we're just
not in our in our means and we were like
we're living here you'll be a poet and
I'll open a restaurant like I'm like
I'll burn it all to the ground it's that
enchanting okay our daughter will work
at the movie theater it's like that
anyway so we're going to see it probably
helped that we were there to be with
Eckhart Tolle do you know who Eckhart
Tolle is yes yes
but I haven't like followed him followed
him I'm not gonna there's no quiz yeah
all right fine but you know he's he's
incredible he's he's one of the he's
changed my life and we're sitting there
and on the last night he's like we're
going to do a surprise evening this is
after all just talks about reality and
Consciousness and love and compassion
and all this stuff he's like for the
last night I want to do something
special and we're going to have some
laughs and he
Julia he played clips from Seinfeld and
talked about them can you and the clip
that he played was you on the train
when you're are you kidding me yeah no
he play and he goes so it's you and you
know the lights go off and it's your
inner monologue yeah and he goes this
just shows the insanity of the ego
and and it's true it helps us laugh at
what our minds are doing to us they're
torturing us is this am I ever going to
get out of this situation am I ever
going to eat what if I have to pee like
they're not your friends and he was like
this is what good comedy can do is it
helps us laugh and put some distance
instead of identifying with that voice
that you so beautifully play as the
actor but also the the voiceover it's
showing us it's give do you know what I
mean when I say it puts the distance
between yeah sure when you're laughing
at it it's not you yeah somehow you're
I'm gonna say you're in the Observer
place you're just kind of
dispassionately going like what a trip
to be a human so I thought maybe you
would enjoy it I love that I can't yeah
I can't believe it actually I couldn't
either I was uh I was pregnant in that
scene I was very pregnant with my first
son yeah because I was really sick did
he get paid
yeah he's inside yeah he's a actually he
owns a piece of the show
unlike me
so without forcing it maybe the answer
is no but is there a spiritual side to
you to frame you you're in the safest
place to believe whatever you want um I
I'm
history of all of this yeah
um but I don't
have a a god per se that I pray to the
mystery is the god the mystery of yes I
am in awe of the mystery of it all can I
give you one of my favorite quotes go
and then I die
um Barry Taylor the road manager for AC
DC of all people said that God is the
name of the blanket we put over the
mystery to give it a shape so isn't that
beautiful we're all trying to find a way
to talk about this phenomenon that most
of us aren't talking about like you and
I are on a space rock you and I are
independent seemingly independent
conscious beings that woke up in this
situation and most people's strategies
it seems to me is don't talk about it
let's get some ice cream look I get it I
take days where I just eat ice cream oh
yeah yeah yeah
you can't live in that world forever
it'll literally depress me it'll make me
go a little bit off my thing but
I find great solace in going like isn't
that I mean here we are
we're here right now yeah and we don't
know how we got here we don't know where
we're going right but having even the
word mystery is a way for you to
participate with it I'm going to put
this to you see if you agree because you
might not understand it but you can
experience it is that is that right yes
and I'm in awe of what I don't know
and I is a feeling yeah I mean it's like
I was watching something on the TV about
they were talking about the Hubble
telescope
and
everything that they have discovered
which is that there are all of these uh
um what am I trying to say oh God
clusters
it's usually clusters
there's so much more out there than
anybody had ever known okay
so much more yeah and all of these
universes well beyond other universes
everywhere right and I'm just like huh
yeah and that there was an amount of
glass glass question mark and mirrors
question mark I know you know what I
mean like what are we doing that we're
seeing that for there's certain things
in life that I've had conversations with
Scientists where I'm like oh I just saw
the look on your face where you know
there's no way to explain this to me
like you see that I'm missing the
reading required to just begin this
conversation yeah that's how I feel
about the Hubble telescope yeah because
I'm just over here going mirrors
it's it
it's either
like
that's right
yeah but I am in awe of what it is this
is
telling us does it increase your anxiety
or reduce your anxiety or a little bit
of both I would say it's a little bit of
both I'm uh but you know I it makes me
concerned about our insignificance yes
interesting yeah because that that is
what that question was getting at it's
like on one hand
it's almost like what are you worried
about that's anxiety reduction and then
on the other hand it's like oh my God
we're it's we're nothing like we're just
a drop yeah and I think about that with
the climate crisis it's you know yeah uh
uh the planet's gonna be just fine guys
you know that so we met at that stand-up
show and I oh that's right yes yes I got
off stage and I was like I have a
climate change bit where and I didn't do
it and they forgot I've just forgot
driving home I was like all right and
it's that premise you just nailed it as
I go
life will be okay I don't know if we'll
be okay yeah but like no no we won't be
okay right right the planet will carry
on in some form and as it has before yes
extinctions and it's gonna it's gonna be
okay and even after no I'm not saying
we're gonna be okay no I know okay
NDC thing nrdc you did an incredible
that's the natural resources defense
counsel for those who are listening yes
that was such a fun show but you and
Tony were the only people that Tony Hale
were the and my wife I was only playing
to you guys do you remember of course I
do you were so [__] funny that is so
touching because oh no it's not touching
it's true you were hilarious I got off
station I was like I don't I went into a
Fugue State because it wasn't an ideal
setup for comedy was outside no it was a
bad setup it was a lot of very very
leisured rich powerful people in couches
in couches it's not and I go out and I
say like one of the a line that as a as
a spoiled performer I'm like way till
they hear this line I say it it gets
nothing it gets Beyond nothing I'm being
heckled by police sirens and like
spotlights going on buildings but I
start losing it and making fun of the
show and you and Tony it was it's a
career highlight we're falling out of
your seat like like the Apollo it was
one of my favorite memories but no one
else was laughing that's not true by the
way other people were laughing was has
Tony been on your podcast yeah oh good
isn't he fun and he's a spiritual person
very yeah yeah and a beautiful person
wonderful man I just uh I just faced
FaceTime with him the other day because
he's doing a show in Rome and feeling a
little I know feeling a little homesick
and I love him so much so I was happy to
talk we read our daughter his book which
every time I mentioned it Archibald yeah
Archibald saves the something well
archbald's next big thing Nick thank you
sorry yeah I'm embarrassed but that
message has a very Eckhart Tolle message
remember the lesson is just B just B
yeah are you
in your mystery appreciation space yeah
because even as I just said it I was
like right we can do it right now no one
needs to know you can just settle into
yourself and just be like when I talk to
Val my very wise wife I'll be like
oh sometimes I worry that I'm just
stringing along crumbs like of pleasure
or an Accolade or some sort of high and
there's these long moments of string in
between them and all of us are just
trying to maximize the good and minimize
the bad and sometimes I feel like a
mouse scurrying on the ground looking
for breadcrumbs instead of I think
potentially sitting at the banquet table
and the banquet table is the present
moment and just going like because
that's what she brought me back into she
goes Pete are you doing that right now
is that happening right now it's Elaine
on the train I'm not trying to be funny
it's my brain going
all you're doing is
delaying the inevitable none of this
matters you're just trying to feel good
oh bruh [__] oh everyone's just
trying to feel good right but when you
go will you relax brain and I always say
drop anchor into the present moment and
just go like wait are you a meditator
yeah good are you yeah what flavor damn
Joe yeah you got to do the Tam do it my
voice is a little thrown it's usually
better yes what's your Mantra I'm just
kidding it's a secret
um how long have you been doing TM a
couple years it's a new thing yeah I
haven't been yes did you tell Jerome
Jerome was the one who put me in touch
with my TM teacher what's her name his
his name okay I wondered if we had the
same one who's your David Lynch people
here in L.A okay same
does your Mantra start with an S no
sh I'm just kidding like you smell it
and what is it it's ATM ATM yes you are
the queen you know you are do you what's
your experience been uh with it is it is
it helping you it's helpful yeah uh it's
hard for me to remember to do it yeah
I'm not
I'm not as
as I should be the routine of it comes
and goes yeah
and you have to but it is something I
can go to and sometimes I need to go to
it yeah but the other thing too I think
is you know getting out into the natural
world has been a has been a huge source
of uh uh Comfort to me you know nature
yeah just getting outside getting
outside and
uh you know there's a I think it's the
Japanese have an expression called
Forest bathing which you I know doesn't
that tell you everything that's great
and so just getting out there and being
in nature and moving in nature it's uh
it's a very good idea for the brain
something you're smaller than things see
Leila our daughter loves to watch TV
first thing in the morning because it
happened during the lockdown and now
it's a habit we're trying to break so we
go you can watch TV but we have to do
one thing outside first and what I
notice is when you're Under The Canopy
of the sky and a tree that's bigger than
you yeah it's just that's the spirit you
should be going into your day it's like
you in the Hubble you're small actually
right you think if you can put a TV show
into your awareness that's all that's
happening at least you're being
titillated right actually you're a part
of a thing right you're you're a tile in
a mosaic so going outside does that the
color green also they say it just lowers
your blood pressure and all that so that
is we can say that's like part of your
oh that's interesting I'm sure you're
right about that right in the way that
red and yellow they say makes you hungry
which is why McDonald's is red and
yellow shoes really I know
I know that explains why I'm hungry
because I'm looking at these two things
behind your head yeah bam oh my God red
and yellow I'm going to McDonald's after
this don't do it environmentally
speaking I promise you I won't where's
that foot in that place I know this is a
a tricky thing and I'm certainly not
hanging it on you but environmentally
speaking and I actually just started
eating chicken again I was vegan for a
long time and I just started eating
chicken again because I [__] hate
chickens no just kidding but I I just
wanted to simplify my diet I was
noticing I was eating a lot of processed
stuff and I was like I'm gonna give in I
was already eating fish which I know
environmentally isn't great so what I'm
saying is I'm I'm in the problem as well
so I'm not saying it's just interesting
to me that
what is the attitude of the
environmental groups when it comes to
the huge impact that that animal plants
and processing does to the earth when we
go like when you're going against
someone's stomach and their culture you
know what I mean yeah it's so hard when
we all know I think it's worse than
Planes Trains cars combined well I think
food waste is our big problem in terms
of uh in terms of
uh emissions and uh contributing to the
the climate crisis but yeah the world I
mean I am not a vegan I should be uh the
world would be a better place if we all
were period end of story right I mean
that's so just a fact psychologically to
unpack it as someone who was vegan the
threat of that of the vegan at the table
it's it's uncomfortable it's it's like
because like it's not just a piece of
chicken it's literally your mother's
love like that's what you think it is
like my mom made Rose what are you
talking about I'm saying symbolically my
mom would cook me roast chicken
stop eating roast chicken
yeah but that's what I mean or her apple
pie has eggs in it has milk in it like
these things are
way more complicated meaning you can't
go at it in a Headway it I mean it has
to address the heart it's almost like
the only way to do it would be a reboot
you know what I mean like yeah wipe
everybody's memory and then be like
we've been vegan the whole time and then
be like oh your mom used to make you
seitan or whatever it is right I mean I
just I'm sharing my own overwhelm
because that seems like such a good
solution uh but at the same time here we
are have you ever almost died
yeah I mean I had cancer so and I
survived it I wasn't trying to be
distasteful I asked everybody that
question oh yeah but I'm answering it
yeah I'm not being distasteful either
yeah in that moment I was like oh [__] I
probably should have been sensitive
about that tell me tell me about it what
did you learn uh I learned
what did I learn I'm that I'm very
grateful to be here and uh I don't know
what I learned it was uh was it harder
than you thought it would be
oh yeah
yeah it was a bear and a [__] half
yeah yeah
I mean in what in what way
well
um
I I had to go through chemotherapy and
it was a wicked chemotherapy that made
me really really sick right yeah and
then I had to have a lot of surgery and
it was uh you know I didn't it was like
getting hit from behind like a [__]
speed train speeding coming at me from
behind that's the whole thing was just
like
what the [__] are you talking about you
know but
um uh but I got through it did you how
did you feel about all of the other I
sometimes feel like when I go to the
hospital you present them with a pass
and they either stamp it and you can
leave and your freedom pass is renewed
or they don't stamp it and now you're in
that side of things you were on that
side of things you were held you had a
disease you had to deal with it how did
you feel and how did you deal with the
rest of us carpenter ants going around
being like
American Auto my favorite show and it
deleted it and you're like I might not
be here no I didn't think it wasn't like
that was not my Approach no I my point
of view was not like that at all I was
very much uh just on uh getting uh
getting through one day after another
because I really was quite ill and so
um I was not
um I was very
about us what you know I was just laser
focused on
um getting better yeah I mean for real
right yeah and and accepting
um kindnesses from other people that was
you know my my circle of friends you
know they they circled around me in a
way that was very
um
comforting I mean beautiful too right I
mean it's including our friend Tony Hill
who was a dear heart yeah of course of
course yeah laughs Hospital laughs
always really sure I mean can you
imagine yeah there's something so human
about what you're saying right now you
know what I mean it's like
we're all cancer no we're all in a tight
spot yeah and laughing is such a gift so
I'm just it's the only way out yeah
that's right it really is what takes you
out doesn't it yeah it takes you out of
your situation and it's a it's a joyful
experience right just to laugh Seinfeld
told that story about visiting a friend
in the hospital and he was dying and he
hocked something up like it just had to
be addressed and he was talking about
how he was going to The Comedy Cellar
and he goes I'll tell you I'm really
looking forward to the hummus tonight
and like he said they both died laughing
which is just the best because it's a
risk it's it's a little Bill and Ted's
it's a risk like can I make fun just a
little bit yeah how gross that was right
but the person is there too I mean
you're not the disease the disease is
happening to you you're not the phlegm
right I mean you had to experience that
too you you were still Julia you were
there yeah like you were comfortable
with the weird things or the valve that
they got on you or whatever it might be
right but did people just I mean
I guess I'm looking for a comment on
that but really it doesn't really need
one yeah it just is and I got through it
and it was uh thankfully and I was very
talk about a happy uh you know talk
about getting back to work was just
about the most joyful thing ever after
that experience because we had to shut
down our show I was making Veep at the
time we had to shut it down for
practically a year while I went through
this thing and then but then I came back
yeah and the experience of being on set
and making really good [__] stuff
again was just about as elevated as it
gets talk about gratitude yeah my God in
heaven I have never been happier to get
back on set incredible yeah and it's
almost like you did a year the
quarantine too I mean you you kind of
had an experience of that it's like
sometimes life gets shut down that's
right and did that help you roll with
that a little bit with the quarantine
yeah oh yeah yeah I took that quarantine
seriously yeah you know I was not I was
like um I think uh I'm not going to be
arrogant about this at all yeah yeah
yeah and strangely good for the
environment turned out um yeah yeah
exactly have you ever seen a ghost you
seem like a lady who's seen a ghost uh
no have you I think Carter because you
really seem like a lady look behind you
right now
um I have you
um no the ghost of my cat uh jumps up on
my bed reliably meaning if I go and stay
at my mom's house and sleep in my old
bed in the morning I'll wake up by the
the ghost of my cat jumping on the bed
and I'm not I'm hungry for that stuff I
love the unexplainable but when I say it
happens every time it's it's bizarre
it's really bizarre really yeah and I
feel it it curls up on me and I'm like
hi Clem it's Clem it's not marm it's
Clem as in clementine Clementine he died
in the house and marm snuggled right up
on him and purred it was beautiful so I
think Clem's Still rocking or just like
it could like it doesn't seem the flavor
of our conversation but it could just be
like some weird confusing all time is
happening simultaneously so Clem is just
kind of in the house not as a spirit but
just like a glitch yeah what about a UFO
anything unexplainable a psychic ever
blow your mind you seem like a lady
because I've been to psychics and they
were she was mind-blowing but I can't
remember anything she said except that
she knew stuff she couldn't have known
yes and
um
but I can't I don't remember what it was
that's okay I'm so sorry
facing cancer and thinking about the end
did you think it was the end do you
think no no
oh
when we die it's everyone's death is
that the end is that lights out or are
you open is that a mystery uh that's a
mystery and it's you know my father
passed about I actually lost my dad and
I also lost my sister within a year of
each other and I think I'm very much
thinking that I'm not going to say
they're around but
I I
um they're in me I don't know how to say
it you know the that I mean I believe in
the
somehow the spirit but I don't know what
what I'm talking about
but I'm going to start a church and it's
based on what I just said and donations
and donations it's mainly about
donations it's called the ATM Church
Aston elf
[Laughter]
I knew because of your vibiness that
that would be okay
here's here's my question here's here's
a 15 second and a perfect time to take a
sip I think awareness there's only one
awareness and we share it
and so therefore your father and your
sister I'm so sorry by the way are
literally with you meaning that
awareness contains all everything all
things so when I say to my daughter for
example I'm always with you I sort of
mean that literally I don't mean
physically but like we are connected and
I think most of the better more mystical
leaning spiritual practices from Judaism
and Kabbalah to Mystical Christianity
certainly to Hinduism Buddhism would say
awareness is awareness and it's one
awareness right it's having a dream yes
and in the dream I'm this and you're
that but behind it there's only one when
you really meditate next time you're
doing your TM with your non-sh Mantra
try and think about like
it's just this there's just one
sensation of being like the Old
Testament God I am that I am I am emness
and we're all sharing that emness of
course your father I'm I'm one of those
people that would be like
where could they go
[Laughter]
but have you lost anybody really
important to you in your life I don't
mean physically where they could go I'm
not trying to negate the loss I'm saying
no no I know I know yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah I haven't yet no good well I mean
eventually it's all going to happen to
everybody but right yeah but um yeah
tell me what that made you think what
what what give me the wiser wiser than
me oh [__] I thought you were about to
no I wasn't I thought I was talking like
someone who hasn't lost someone I
thought that's maybe what I stepped in
no no no no no no no no I was wondering
I I was asking never mind I was asking
you because I thought maybe you lost
someone and that you weren't feeling
okay no never mind never mind I love it
no wisdom here nothing zero nah [__]
thing okay let's let's do a speed round
and we'll get you out of here it's a
little toasty in here I think it's these
extra bodies I am warm can you turn the
air on Katie please yeah wasn't that
[__] up the sound it's quiet it's
whisper quiet nice
this is a fun part of the show when I
watch Comedians and cards the only thing
I care about is what they order and how
they order it so these moments
how we are as we're turning on the air
as interesting there you go I'll put on
69 it's the only funny one
can you tell me a great lesson you've
learned about motherhood just a quick
one something someone told you a
perspective an attitude a little line
are you holding for sound because the
plan is going by
um well I can tell you this
I can tell you that if I were giving
myself advice as a young mother
I would the advice I would say is please
relax
it's gonna be fine
we need to hear I'm going to tell Val
that you said that yeah because we're
over here going like yeah is Lima yeah I
know oh my God
loses her [__] a lot she had a melt a
full meltdown because one kid said that
swing is higher than that one and she
said no it's not I'm with her by the way
that kid's wrong
what about show business is there a
mantra that's carried you through show
business that did you well
it doesn't even have to be a clean line
just to let the greatest lesson you've
learned or a lesson that you've learned
about navigating this it could even be
what we've already said um I would say
it would be to trust your instincts
trust me in when you're performing
uh generally speaking generally speaking
because that brings me to acting what's
a great what's something you try to hold
in your mind or not hold in your mind
when you're acting is there a great
lesson someone's taught you about how to
perform
oh listen yeah
you gotta listen hard to beat the Great
but you really do have a and a lot of
actors make that mistake
I've look I've not listened and there
have been a lot of times where I had to
go like can you just
can you just be here just please yeah
because you know sometimes we're just
trying to remember our lines and it can
be a real bummer yeah but that's where
my wound so feel growing up in a
household way didn't necessarily feel
recognized helps because I'm going like
that's and it helps in stand up it's
like I need everyone
with lock in and that's the gift yes you
know what I mean yes yes what about uh
and we'll act in comedy
and I know you don't believe in a God
but some
mystery the great lesson you've learned
about the mystery I mean we're both
doing it right now what do you carry
with you when it comes to not freaking
out that we're that we're here and we
don't know what's going on
um
well
sometimes when I'm feeling particularly
anxious about something
anyway I love it already no love the
area but I made me think legitimately I
think to myself well
at least I can still breathe
and I and I do actually I know that
sounds so [__] simple-minded but I
just think
okay I can breathe I can still get air
into my lungs
I'll always remember that answer why did
you put down that answer
I don't know great answer sort of oh is
that that's your Jerry that was my
Michael Richards
no yeah yeah wrong one wrong
last question because it is just too
warm in here yeah and you've got that
movie coming out I got a lot to do these
guys have to pee they've got to get my
face cream is what they've got to do
here's you leave the room
and this is my real Jerry impression you
just did your audition he goes that was
fantastic that was her go get her
yeah wait do it again that was fantastic
that's her go get her yeah it's not bad
it's not bad it's I wouldn't do it for
him why I met Jerry once and I and he
complimented something of mine and I
went like this
and I could tell from his face I blew it
like I I was too big no
you don't think no I'm sure yeah I was
just like that just seemed like
something he'd be like he did the mind
mine explode do we need the Mind explode
yeah that's good okay all right well got
my little key bump of validation for the
day you're fabulous thank you for the
kind you're a true Talent thank you for
having me thank you for doing it very
very Charming to be here one final
question go you're gonna love it though
I hope can you tell me the time in your
life you laughed harder than you've ever
laughed here's the caveat though it
doesn't have to be a good story maybe
you were a kid maybe someone fell maybe
someone farted these usually get people
there I just want you you're crying
laughing
where are you how old are you who are
you with oh geez I gotta think
I was in the Glee Club in fifth grade or
maybe it was seventh grade no it had to
have in seventh grade
and we had to sing this stupid [__]
song
uh which was called what was it called
turn around and you wander around and
you're tuned in advance do you know this
song does anyone know what I'm talking
about is that Drake
I can't remember what it was but it was
like singing about children aging and
and around and you're a young woman
walking out of the door or something
like that reimagining of Sunrise so it
was sort of and it I was standing next
to my friend and we were supposed to
sing it straight and I
we got into so much trouble because I
was doubled over it was the stupidest
song we just sing for this huge recital
with all the parents and I couldn't get
through it and it was really bad
because of the stupidness of the song or
just the pressure or just the like
forbidness the Forbidden first of all it
was stupid yeah I didn't want to sing it
she didn't either it was [__] it was
just an [__] Song and then we had to
sing it seriously in front of all the
parents and the teachers and we were
forbidden from laughing please that's
all you need that's all you need singing
be forbidden is unbelievable singing and
forbidden are often in the answer it's
often like church oh really yes it has
to be forbidden we Valley reminds me of
one where Val and I I did this corporate
gig it was actually worse than the
corporate it was a private birthday
party very sweet people and the woman
asked the guy asked if I would stay and
listen to his wife's thing no yes no you
didn't yes and I stayed and look what
kind of music was she she wanted to sing
um I will always love you oh no
and in her defense I
part version the band played the wrong
version so inner defense but Val and I
are sitting there with This Woman's
family and she's up there being like uh
uh like just kind of uncomfortable and
off and I was like I can't wait
to fart in the car not fart but like
laugh about this but it's gonna be
incredible but were you able to keep
your [__] together I kept it together
yeah oh I knew thank you yeah it's the
best acting I've ever done it's like
that was good it was very good wow
because you know what even as I'm
telling it
I like singing poorly singing so
vulnerable I I don't really like I can't
fully get behind just like massacring
this woman because I get it I feel the
same way about stuttering I've never
laughed at someone stuttering making fun
of a stutter it's just too vulnerable oh
yeah you know what I mean absolutely
yeah I'm not alone on that completely
Julia Louis yes
thank you Pete thank you thank you so
much for having me would you please keep
it crispy is how we end the guest says
keep it crispy all I can say it doesn't
mean anything it's not a trap it's just
how we it feels like a trap it's a trap
it's kind of a keep it crispy
did I do it you did it perfectly what
are these drinks oh this is called Magic
mind that was for you
are you working today yeah drink this I
mean
I'm working right now aren't I yeah for
sure you should have drank it before the
interview to be honest it was a little
what is it
um it has a little bit of caffeine 35
milligrams of caffeine so it's got
matcha nootropics you know vitamins that
help you think yeah it has adaptogens
that help you cope with stress so the
mix of the caffeine and the adaptogens
give you this very Even Flow State I
love it really I'll give you a bunch you
can take both of these but if you're
doing emails or work or tomorrow for
your photo shoot even just to like kind
of stay alert yeah I'll give you a bunch
oh how fabulous it's I just sent a name
drop just send a bunch to Anne lamotte
like it's my thing who would be great on
your pod yes as a matter of fact yes and
who was quoted by Jane Fonda in my
podcast believe it I this is I'm not
just flattering no is a complete
sentence I know if they wanted us to
talk about them more better in our
writing they should have behaved better
that's one of my favorite I just
butchered it but when you write I wrote
a book you write about your family yeah
and you tell the truth and you're like
do I have to right ask their permission
and Anne Lamont says if they wanted you
to write better about them they should
have behaved differently nice and I'm
like oh she's [__] bad yeah she's I
was just gonna say I don't know if she's
old enough but wait until she's I don't
know I don't know
yeah I think so you might have to wait
she has to make me have to wait but um
do more stress less I like this thank
you so much more magic mine and thank
you so much thank you for having me what
a pleasure pleasure
[Music]
thank you